the second episode of the final season
of Game of Thrones was full of
long-awaited reunions references to
seasons past and clues about the battle
that lies ahead here are 14 details you
might have missed and of course warning
spoilers are coming the north is in full
battle preparation mode and the slight
changes in the opening credits reflect
that showing new trenches lining the
borders of Winterfell the episode opens
on Jamie who's found himself on trial by
Daenerys and the Starks he must answer
for the murder of Danny's father King
Aerys ii as well as for his role in Ned
Stark's untimely death when Daenerys
demands that Jaime explained why he
deserted Cersei he responds because this
goes beyond loyalty this is about
survival
his words echo Brienne's in the season 7
finale Oh loyalty when Tyrion throws his
weight behind Jaime
Daenerys does not react kindly saying
perhaps Jaime trusts his little brother
to defend him right up and told the
moment he slits my throat her wording
beckons back to the prophecy the woods
which told young Cersei in the books the
valonqar shall wrap his hands about your
pale white throat and choke the life
from you
valonqar means little brother in
Valyrian which is why Cersei always
believed Tyrion would be the one to kill
her the show left out this part of the
prophecy so we can't be sure Tyrion will
play any significant role in Circe's
death when it's decided that Jaime can
join their ranks grey worm but
grudgingly returns his sword known as
widows wail what she owned it widows
wail it's one of the two blades at the
Lannisters forged after melting down ice
the ancestral sword of House Stark it's
sister sword is Oathkeeper which Jaime
bestowed upon Brienne now with Jaime
serving under Brienne's command the two
blades of ice have been reunited for the
time since Ned left Winterfell in season
one at the exact moment that Jamie is
rearmed we hear a familiar musical cue
the song is Jamie's theme first played
when he recounts to Brienne the real
reason he killed Aerys Targaryen kept
your oath death and again when he was
headed to Riverrun to break the black
fishes siege
[Music]
there are new as well as old weapons as
Aria checks in with guns reappear she
asked him to make from her sketches it
looks like this is the design that the
show's weapons master Tommy Dunn spoke
of in a recent interview with Vanity
Fair he said there is one creation in
season 8 that is absolutely phenomenal
in that it's able to be reverse
engineered and made into two different
items if that's true this double-ended
tool will prove handy when it's time for
aria to face down white walkers or cross
a few more people off her kill list the
flirtation scene between Aria and Gendry
visually mirrors one of their past
interactions in season two
during the Lannister brother reunion
Tyrion repeats his tried-and-true joke
from all the way back to season one how
would you like to die Tyrion son of
Tywin my own bed at the age of 80 with a
belly full of wine and a girl's mouth
around mic
then Tyrion half jokes that maybe he'll
still get his last shot at murdering
Cersei saying maybe after I'm dead I'll
march down to King's Landing and rip her
apart
it sounds light-hearted but really this
could be a grim foreshadowing of Tyrion
and many others being reanimated as
whites after the meeting to discuss
tactics Jon stands with his former
brothers Samwell and edy the latter of
whom announces and now our watch begins
it's a return to the oath of the
Brotherhood gathers begins after Jon
announced that his watch had ended back
in season six well what'd you send it
now the brothers must again take on the
burden of defending the realm next
there's a doomsday romance scene between
Aria and Gendry he confides in her that
he's Roberts bastard and the last of the
Baratheon it's a direct reversal of the
scene in season 3 when ru revealed to
him her true identity as a stark it's
Arya of how stuck their physical Union
echoes Roberts and Ned's proposed union
of their houses underneath the crypts of
Winterfell in season 1 I have a son you
have a daughter when they undress Arya
reveals some grisly scars the result of
stab wounds inflicted on her by the wave
in season six
meanwhile in front of Winterfell
fireplace Jamie holds a spontaneous
knighting ceremony for Brienne on the
eve of her biggest battle yet she's
proclaimed the night of the Seven
Kingdoms which is the title of this
episode it's also the name of a trio of
novellas written by george RR martin as
a spinoff from the Song of Ice and Fire
series the books follow a chivalrous
Knight known as Sir Duncan the tall
who's actually mentioned several times
in the show I could tell you about ser
Duncan the tall
at a 2016 fan convention Martin
confirmed that Brienne was descended
from Sir Duncan we can guess that's
where she got her unusual height and her
bravery after Brienne's induction into
the knighthood Podrick performs Jenny of
old stones his own impressive rendition
of a song from the original Song of Ice
and Fire books the song references Jenny
of old stones a character from the books
who was married to Prince Duncan
Targaryen Jenny this version of the song
included new lyrics and the episodes
closing credits even debuted a cover of
the song performed by Florence in the
machine Podrick singing is paired with
the montage showing the people of
Winterfell making their final
preparations the music and visuals evoke
this scene from Return of the King set
to the sad tune of Pippin song the edge
of night
[Music]
the similar mood makes sense specially
given that the director of the impending
battle scene sighted Lord of the Rings
as an inspiration one thing is for sure
the episode ends on a decidedly ominous
note so there you have it did we miss
anything let us know in the comments